très concrètement
les forêts là aujourd'hui elles sont menacées
pourquoi les émissions augmentent et il y a des responsables à ça
ma question est très simple
contre toute à l'énergie
par exemple une entreprise française
qui construit des bombes climatiques à vous entendre
vous ne pouvez rien
contre des multimilliardaires français
qui détruisent des conditions de vie sur terre
avec leur jet privé
à vous entendre
où vous ne pouvez rien
contre des banques comme benzema
des banques françaises qui continuent de financer
des méga projets climaticides à vous entendre vous ne pouvez rien
donc ma question elle est très simple ce soir
à quoi servez-vous
pourquoi faites-vous systématiquement le choix de l'influence